Esta vez tenemos un problema
realmente interesante.
Aquí tenemos una balanza en la cual
hemos puesto 3 masas,
éstas 2 rojas que hemos denominado
con "x" tienen la misma masa,
ésta tercera que le hemos llamado "y",
que tiene una masa distinta,
es importante pensar que no necesariamente
son iguales "x" y "y",
pero ahora veamos la situación,
lo que vemos en la balanza es que
la suma de las "x" y la "y",
están en equilibrio con estos 8 kilogramos
que tenemos del otro lado.
Lo primero que te voy a preguntar es, si
¿puedes escribir una relación matemática
que establezca esta relación?
que toda la masa que está de este lado
es exactamente igual a la masa que está del otro lado.
Observemos nuestra situación
con más cuidado.
Del lado izquierdo la masa total
son 2 masas "x" y una "y",
o sea, lo puedo escribir como
"2x" más una "y"...
mmm... a ver, voy a escribirlo más hacia el centro
para que sea más claro,
tenemos "2x" más "y"
y esa es la masa total del lado izquierdo, "2x" más "y".
La masa total del lado derecho es 8,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8... o sea que es igual a 8.
Observamos que la balanza
está en equilibrio,
o sea la masa total del lado izquierdo es igual a la masa total del lado derecho y podemos usar el signo igual.
Ahora quiero preguntarte,
utilizando solo la información que tenemos aquí,
¿podemos hacer algo
para resolver para "x" o "y"?
¿hay algo que podamos hacer?
Parece que tenemos poca información,
o sea, si yo tomara de este lado y quitara la "y",
entonces para mantener el equilibrio tendría
que del otro lado quitar algo equivalente a "y",
pero como no sé que es,
de la misma manera,
algebraicamente si yo restara "y" de ambos lados,
entonces ahora del lado derecho
voy a seguir teniendo un "-y"
y lo mismo pasaría con la "x", o sea,
como "x" depende de "y" y "y" de "x",
no puedo eliminar con facilidad a cada una.
Por suerte para nosotros,
tenemos suficientes cubos "x" y "y",
entonces voy a tomar un cubo "x"
y ponerlo en la otra balanza
y también voy a poner
un cubo "y" en la balanza.
Y ahora voy a poner tantos cubos
1 necesite yo del lado derecho,
hasta encontrar el punto de equilibrio.
Es obvio que si no pongo nada del otro lado,
entonces la balanza no estaría en equilibrio,
pero voy a poner tantos cubos sean necesarios
para llegar al punto de equilibrio.
Y observo, que llegamos al punto de equilibrio
cuando puse 5 cubos de 1 kilogramo del lado izquierdo.
Entonces ahora te vuelvo a preguntar,
¿podríamos expresar de una manera
matemática esto que tenemos aquí?
que tenemos una "x" y una "y"
y un 5 de este lado.
Entonces tenemos una "x" más una... a ver,
voy a volver a escribirlo más hacia el centro...
tenemos una "x" más "y"
y aquí tenemos un 5,
podemos observar que la masa total de ambos
lados es la misma y entonces podemos,
otra vez usar el signo igual.
Y otra vez, tomando esta información aislada,
pues no sé cuanto vale ni "x" ni "y",
o sea no sé si "y" es 1
ó "x" es 4 o al revés,
pero algo interesante que podemos observar
es que ahora utilizando toda la información
de las dos balanzas que aquí tenemos,
podremos saber el valor de "x" y el de "y"
y me gustaría darte unos segundos para que pienses cómo podríamos abordar esta situación.
Vamos a pensarlo de esta manera,
si ahora yo sé que "x" más "y" es igual a 5,
entonces de este lado,
¿cuántos cubos yo tendría...?
mejor dicho,
¿cuánta masa yo tendría que quitar
de este lado a partir de lo que ya conozco?
Ya sabemos que "x" más "y" es igual a 5 kilogramos,
entonces yo solo tendría que retirar
5 kilogramos de este lado
y obviamente "1x" y "1y" de este
lado y eso revelaría el valor de "x".
Pero ahora mejor vamos a pensarlo
en términos algebraicos,
en esencia al retirar de este lado de la balanza una "x"
y una "y", yo estoy restando a "x" y "y".
A ver, entonces voy a escribirlo...
menos...
no, mejor lo voy a escribir de esta manera...
como "-1x" más "y",
¿y ahora qué tengo que hacer del lado derecho?
Bueno, si ya sabemos que
"x" más "y" es igual a 5,
entonces tendré que retirar 5 kilogramos
del lado derecho de la balanza.
Y todo esto lo puedo realizar,
solo porque tengo la información
que me proporcionó la segunda balanza.
Y entonces lo que voy a hacer aquí es restar 5,
porque es lo que sabemos,
de este lado vamos a restar 5.
Entonces, si vamos a restar una "x"
y una "y" de este lado...
mmm...
déjame reescribirlo de esta manera...
Vamos a distribuir
el signo menos en las dos
y entonces sería lo mismo
que poner "-x" menos "y".
Veamos que pasará del lado izquierdo,
entonces si yo tengo "2x" y le quito una,
pues nada más me queda una "x",
si yo tengo una "y" y quito una "y",
entonces ya no hay "y" y visualmente
lo podríamos ver de este lado de la balanza,
solo tenemos una "x",
ahora  vamos del lado derecho.
Entonces como quitamos "x" más "y" que vale 5,
vamos a restar 5, porque eso ya lo sabíamos.
Entonces 8 menos 5
nos va a quedar igual a 3.
Claro, 8 menos 5 es igual a 3
y entonces utilizando
toda la información que nos dieron estas dos balanzas, ahora podemos ver que "x" vale 3.
Ahora vamos con otra pregunta,
bueno, ya fuimos capaces de obtener
el valor de la masa de "x",
¿podremos ser capaces de determinar
el valor de la masa de "y"?
Entonces podemos regresar otra vez a las balanzas
y en este caso, ésta será más útil,
si sabemos que "x" más "y" es igual a 5
y también sabemos ahora que "x" vale 3,
entonces reemplazaremos a "x" por 3
y vamos a reescribir esto como 3 más "y"...
sí, 3 más "y" es igual a 5
y ahora podríamos decir,
vamos a quitar 3 de ambos lados,
o sea si quito 3 del lado izquierdo,
tendré que quitar 3 del lado derecho
y así lo tengo que hacer
para conservar el equilibrio.
Y que sería equivalente a restar 3
de ambos lados de mi ecuación,
entonces de este lado solo me queda "y"
y del otro lado me queda un 2.
Y entonces obtuvimos que "x" es igual a 3
kilogramos, y que "y" es igual a 2 kilogramos.
Ahora te toca verificar
que utilizando estas masas ,
la masa total de ambos lados
es la misma.
Y en este caso podemos comprobar
que dos veces 3 es igual a 6 más 2,
entonces la masa total
del lado izquierdo es 8
y está en equilibrio con el otro lado
que vale 8 y 3 más 2 es igual a 5.